if we do this act they are not
religious are not Muslims because it is
that Islam does not call for violence
it is a religion of peace
they still decided on priests but
of Muslim inhabitants that causes the
Muslims of France all Muslims
to respect followed well
average French is all there is one
neighbor this month a co-worker
either the student or the students
middle schoolers be their children are
in the same school and so they know
that they are the Muslims actually the
others wonder is that it's
possible that they remain just Islam
push his followers to commit such
act one is always in the emotion
desolation in sadness all the
world is charlie